title for today is building computers
with bacteriophage
the type of computer that we're keen
about is not
to compete directly with the one on the
desk here we're interested primarily in
implementing computing
in spaces where silicon-based computing
isn't going to work
at least i don't see how it's going to
work such as inside
every living cell in my body okay
so these computers are are going to be
slow
they're going to be very modest in their
computational capacity
but that doesn't matter so much right if
i could for example count
cell division events then i might only
need to track a couple hundred cell
division events
i might only need eight bits as a
register for combinatorial counter
and that would be a lot inside a
biological replicating context
that's a quick introduction to the
computing part
but more to say on that
with bacteriophage and and i want to use
the photograph
shown on on this opening slide to to
begin to talk about bacteriophage if you
haven't heard
anything about them um
if you look at this photo i could ask
very naively
but hopefully of the natural materials
you see represented here
what would you expect to build a
computer from
and eventually many folks will look to
the sandy material and say we could do
something with that
we'd have to clean it up and refine it
and take it forward but
but we know how to do things with
silicon
the bacteriophage are also shown in this
photograph but you can't see them
directly they're they're typically in in
this picture in the ocean
bacteriophage are are eaters of bacteria
they're bacterial viruses and it looks
like they are the most
numerate abundant uh greatest in number
replicating natural systems on earth the
ecologists now
appreciate them well enough to estimate
that earth has about 10 to the 31st
bacteriophage particles on the planet
with us
that's a large number what that
translates to for example
is in the surface waters of the ocean
you might have
a billion bacteriophage particles in a
liter
of ocean water these particles are
typically
small like calcihedral capsids about 60
nanometers across
packaging up genomes that might be 40
000 bases of dna
i'll come back and explore some of those
ideas in more detail
and and so what i'd like you to leave
this
photograph with is the idea that were we
just set out to build computers
with bacteriophage or perhaps from
bacteriophage
i want you to think about the the steps
of refinement the number of moves we'd
have to make
in converting the natural material the
found objects
into engineered objects much like when
you think about engineering a silicon
based computer
you don't simply take that sand and
shovel it into a new pile and say
there's my computer now maybe
you can think of it that way but i see a
lot of computing objects that represent
many more steps of refinement processing
adding in of extrinsic information
shaping and so on and so forth
so so think of biology as a living
material a substrate and as we begin to
through synthetic biology on top of
genetic engineering get better at
working with these materials and
reworking the materials and refining
them what new types of objects we can
make
so i just want to leave you with that
meta notion
don't think of biology as only things
that pre-exist but what happens when we
grind it up and rework it
okay so these bacteriophages are
represented they are eaters of bacteria
and so i wanted to show you a time lapse
movie of bacteria growing
some of these bacteria have been
infected
with the bacterial virus if the cells
are infected with the bacterial virus
they'll turn green
because we've added a gene under the
virus genome that makes the cells when
infected with the virus turn green
some cells will stay dark all right the
cells are these blobs these black blobs
these are about a micron long
these are e coli this is a time lapse
movie of a couple hours under
an automated microscope
and the movie is going to run forward in
time and backwards in time
so there was an infected cell up here
this is now running backwards in time
i hope all right
um now it'll start over infected and the
cell burst
and and that's called lysis and that's
the release of probably a hundred
bacteriophage particles which are
too small to see under the light
microscope so the cell just looks like
it goes away
whereas the cell that was infected down
here continues to grow and divide
and the virus instead of blowing up the
cell has integrated its chromosome
into the bacterial chromosome and gone
dormant
okay so hiv is not dissimilar in that
sense it can
infect and go dormant sometimes
this is the same virus in both the
infected cells so far as we know
identical genetically
and what this represents is is in
developmental biology
a sulfate selection process you have to
decide are you going to blow up the cell
or you're going to go dormant and you
can think of that as a zero one
outcome
within this natural system there are
molecular components that carry out the
all process regulators of gene
expression
that sense the state of the cell and
coordinate that information to help set
the switch
one of the things that's interesting
about this process if i just zoom out
and come back to planet earth for a
second
with 10 to the 31 phage on the planet
probably about 10 percent of them being
very conservative and underestimating
can make these types of decisions that's
10 to the 30th
decision-making phage particles out
there
and they're making this type of decision
about once a day
once about 10 to the fifth seconds
so in other words there's 10 to the 25th
switching events like this happening
every second on earth
they're not all cross-wired immediately
but they are cross-wired further through
the recycling of nutrients and the
ecosystem
that's a pretty significant switching
capacity just running out there
on the planet any questions about what
what you're seeing here or
bacteriophage as a as a quick intro
primer yes sir
decision made what's the question so i'm
putting a
sort of persona into this but in in the
context here it's um
imagine you're the the virus you've just
gotten into the cell
is the best thing to do go dormant and
hang out
and maybe pop out later under different
conditions
or should you immediately reproduce blow
up the cell and release your progeny
if you look at this movie carefully
again these are genetic so far as we can
tell these are genetically identical
cells
running in the same environment now the
micro environment's a little bit
different
the cells alone but if you look at the
movie at the beginning
you'll see that the cell up here which
pops is a bigger cell
whereas the cell here that goes dormant
starts out as a tinier cell when it was
infected
the bacteria are naturally going through
the cycle of growth
pinching off in the middle and so you
get a longer longer cell and then two
smaller cells and that just keeps
repeating
the rod goes out of the poles and
pinches in this paper we published
five years ago we were curious to
understand
under conditions like this can we find
any marker
that is an indicator of what the outcome
will be
and the long story short is we saw that
bigger cells are much more likely to be
popped
and we think that's because evolution
selects for
when you're when you're only going to
blow up half the population
blow up the population that's the bigger
cell so that you get a higher burst of
progeny
right and it just has to do with when
the infection is with respect to the
cell division cycle
so it's a chance in that regard now
whether you want to call that a decision
or not
but it's it's a two-state system right
there's a switching event somewhere in
there
other other questions
from this point forward i'm going to
talk about harvesting some of the gizmos
out of these things and
building data storage logic amplifiers
and other stuff
we can come back if you want to explore
phage biology
it's an interesting area of biology
because it initiated a lot of molecular
genetics
and then sort of fell out of favor but
much more recently as people have
appreciated how many phage there are
and that they're driving a recycling of
the microbial systems in the ocean and
oh by the way those systems are doing
photosynthesis
all of a sudden the biologists are
getting excited about fade yet again
okay so the next few slides
are a reprise of a talk i gave here
almost a year ago
where we had reported not sure the paper
had been published yet but we had just
gotten a one bit data register working
in a chromosome and
and the interaction i had a year ago was
incredibly helpful
um because we had been telling ourselves
the wrong story about our work we've
been representing what we had been doing
in terms of
doing genetic data storage as
engineering set reset
latches and naively
in importing the architecture of maybe a
cross-wired nor gate
where you have feedback and electronics
you know leading to a bi-stable system
and in interacting with this audience
and then writing things down for the
paper afterwards
it became impossible to avoid the
reality which which was we hadn't made
a cross-wired nor set reset latch system
we made a two-state system without any
feedback
that was somehow functionally
multi-multi-state
so i want to just reprise that very
quickly and then i'll move into the
logic amplifier work
this abstract representation here is is
meant to depict a
fragment of of a chromosome all right
and and what we're doing is we're
engineering this region
right here the first thing you need to
know is
is double-stranded dna chemically has an
orientation
which is defined by how the carbons are
connected in
in the sugar in the backbone of the dna
the ribose this is called the five prime
to three prime
directionality of dna
so what that means practically is
double-stranded dna
ends up having an orientation which can
be in one of two states
you can have a section of dna like shown
here
that can be oriented to the right
or i could flip it and paste it back in
and be oriented to the left
and from a chemical and physical
perspective that's it those are the
dominant
states that double-stranded dna can be
occupied
so that we're going to immediately
leverage as a as a pure digital data
register
at a single molecule level right so
to unpack that a little bit more this is
a section of dna
it can be as long as we want so long as
it's
at least 25 bases of dna long
we could probably push it up to 40 to 50
000 bases long
in the work we're doing it's about 50
bases of dna long so the region we're
flipping is 50 different letters
okay the reason we're going to choose to
flip a sequence of dna that has so many
letters
is so that not only do we have a zero
one register but the thing we're
flipping has some genetic activity
it tells the cell to do something and in
the simplest case what we're going to
flip
is going to be called a promoter this is
a region on the dna that recruits an
enzyme called the rna polymerase
to bind the dna and initiate the reading
out of dna
initiation of transcription so if the
promoter is pointing to the left
we'll read out the genes to the left if
the
element with its promoters pointed to
the right will read out the genes to the
right
now these triangles okay on the outside
of this flipping element
those are stolen from bacteriophage
these are the genetic signals that
bacteriophages use to do something a
little bit different
when a phage infects a cell if it
decides to go dormant it has to solve
the problem of integrating
its genome into the host genome and it
uses an enzyme called an integrase
to do that process the integrase is an
enzyme that binds specific sequences on
dna
these triangles and does that push paste
reaction
by changing how these sites are oriented
as discovered
in the early 1980s instead of an
insertion you can get a flipping
all right so that's what we're reusing
so just to repeat this a little bit
we've got a set
stretch of dna call it 50 bases long
if we flip it into this orientation we
can read out a gene to the left
call that a one maybe that gene makes
the cells red
but it could be any gene right it could
be the gene that controls flipping
of another register for example if we
flip it back
that gene turns off another gene turns
on something else turns on
i hadn't fully appreciated the start of
the project how nice this property of
dna
is it exists in one of two states in
terms of its orientation based on the
backbone chemistry
that's a pure single molecule digital
register
okay so we call this colloquially we
call this thing the flippy
and i had mentioned there's this enzyme
from the phage called the integrase
which does this magical thing of
typically in nature inserting but by
re-crafting the sites we can get this
flipping reaction so if we can just
create a pulse of this
enzyme in the cell under our control
then we can drive that zero to one
transition
any questions
yeah dna sort of was
the the chemistry of attaching to his
neighbor was sort of one directional
where did this flipping idea come from
repeat the last part of your question
i i don't understand i thought dna
sort of had a fundamental orientation ah
right so this is the single strand of
dna does
right is sort of five prime it is five
prime to three prime
along one strand but when you have
double stranded dna
the complementary strand has opposite
orientation
so it's five prime to three prime along
the top strand and then running the
other direction five prime to three
prime along the bottom
that allows you to do the flip yeah so i
i should have emphasized double-stranded
dna
can flip it how do you choose which flip
you get
i haven't haven't shown the reset okay
um
a couple other things to note if i have
one in a grace
i'm showing it as a cartoon but this is
a physical object
right um the way it works is and and
this is not perfectly understood
the way it works is the integrase binds
a specific sequence on the dna
so the specificity of the data register
is determined by the protein dna
interaction
such that if i want to have a second
register and i would like it to operate
independently
i'm going to need to harvest and
repurpose a second integrase
with different dna binding specificity
how often does it screw up or not
proceed according to plan
spontaneous switching rates are less
than one in 10 of the 12th cell division
events
let me let me show you some more data um
they're really good i mean shockingly
clean
for biology
let's come back to that
i just want to emphasize if you want
eight bits
you need eight integrases at least right
if you're going up to toggles you might
need 16.
right right now in my laboratory in y2e2
the team has
four integrases sort of under control
that recognize different dna binding
sequences
we know that there's a ton of phage out
there and over the last year just by
starting to publish this work we've
created a new demand or market
for people harvesting integrases that
didn't exist before
and there's a really neat program run
out of university of pittsburgh
sponsored by howard hughes medical
that's called phage hunters where high
school students basically collect phage
and crowdsource the sequencing and
annotation
so i'm hopeful that they're going to be
part of the solution to getting more
gizmos
some integrases that you can find are
not
unidirectional meaning they will
they will flip but then they'll
spontaneously backflip
okay or reset and that gets to the
reliability issue
jerome bonnet who i'll introduce you to
in a moment via photograph
selected a type of integrase called a
serine integrase
that is really nicely unidirectional
okay moreover the
enzymes we're down selecting to don't
require any host cell
cofactors so all the work i'm showing
today is done in e coli but the
stage molecules we're using have been
shown to work
in plants and mammals and so on so the
biochemistry
we believe to be portable across
kingdoms of life
the reset operation takes the same
enzyme and adds to it what's called a
recombination directionality factor
or historically it's been called the
excisionase the oxygenase
as you can imagine in nature is the
enzyme that when present along with the
integrase
causes the integrated virus genome to
excise or pop out
leading to blowing up the cell
so if i take these two proteins and i
express them together
that changes the directionality of the
reaction and i can
reset the dna data register to the exact
sequence i started from completing a
cycle
okay in the abstract
so this was basically the win slide
from a year ago what we're showing here
is um the greenness of cells on the
y-axis
this is data collected from a cytometer
we're basically flowing cells
and getting a very quick microscopic
snapshot and measuring their greenness
so the distribution of single cells
so they're starting out in the one state
that's what a low in green means
we give them a reset pulse they become
green
and when we remove the reset pulse the
cells maintain their greenness
they're storing the green state if we
then give them a set pulse
they lose their greenness they become
red which i'm not showing
and when then they hold that state now
there is dispersion
around the greenness or lack of
greenness
and we believe that to be spontaneous
right um coming from who knows what
people would say noise and gene
expression or i don't know what
this is a log y scale so the means are
probably
shifting by 50 fold in terms of
expressed
protein intensity and that's because
through this digital transition
in the orientation the promoter we can
go from a lot of expression of the left
gene
and little of the right and vice versa
so we get a pretty nice swing
and we can repeat this so what was new a
year ago
was showing for the first time that you
could close the cycle
and then repeat the cycle people had
previously shown just
setting one one-time setting not
rewriting these input pulses are quite
long
you can see that it says 10 cell
doublings
so that might be in this experiment
12 hours a 12 hour input pulse okay
so if you wanted to make a cell division
cycle counter
a 10 cell doubling switching requirement
not so good so we've been pretty keen
to push the speed and this is what it
looks like if you
if you cut the pulse size down uh to two
and a half doublings
okay which probably isn't fast enough
yet um
we we we have seen in movies now that we
can get switching with a 15 minute input
pulse
in cells that are doubling every hour so
we think we can get within the cell
division cycle window
in terms of timing which is key because
cell division cycle counting
is a big application area or underlies
many application areas i should say
what i spent a lot of time talking about
last year was how difficult it was to
get this project to work
that it took us 750 attempts
to do different dna designs to precisely
control the expression levels of the
proteins to get
no switching in the absence of inputs
reliable and complete switching in the
presence of inputs
and no cross contamination between the
set and reset reaction
because they both rely on the integrase
you know if the oxygenase shows up in
the wrong moment
it'll corrupt the set and and so on
so i want to summarize a couple
properties about this
which which really came out of last
year's
talk this isn't a formerly bi-stable
system
as far as i can tell there's no feedback
it's just
it's a non-volatile data register you
know you express the genes
the the data registered sets or resets
and then you get rid of gene expression
and then the dna just sits there
and it gets copied if the dna gets
copied as the cell reproduces
but you don't have to keep expressing
genes right
prior data storage systems in in biology
have relied on cross-regulating
transcription factors like
protein a is turning off protein b or
protein b is turning off protein a
and that means you always have to be
expressing proteins in order to maintain
the state
of your data register but this is a
non-volatile data register with respect
to requiring gene expression you don't
require it once you set the
set the register
and it doesn't seem to require feedback
to hold state
this is very interesting to us it
allowed us for example to grow out the
data registers for a hundred generations
and see if they'd be selected against
would the mutations
cause them to be erased from the
population they're evolutionarily
rock solid out to 100 generations they
don't seem to spontaneously switch
we think they work because we have
really nice analog to digital converters
we can take a continuously varying gene
expression signal
from no gene expression to high gene
expression and everything in between
and at some threshold flip the dna
or don't flip the dna we can do that in
both directions
and uh that's what really came out of
our realization that we hadn't made a
conventional crosswire nor
sr latch
which then begged the question what else
can you make with a to d and and so
that's what
we had in our minds uh last may
now the people here tone and jerome left
and right respectively
are the folks who have done this work
and the work i'm about to
discuss and and in addition to thinking
about what else can you make with a
d converters jerome having just spent
three and a half years getting a one bit
data register was pretty excited to do
something else
and he was keen to try and take genetic
data
into medical diagnostics could you for
example
instrument microbes as part of a early
detection system for diabetes
were biomarkers coming out in your urine
if you could integrate combinations of
biomarker signals might give you a
upstream in time sense of how your
disease state
is emerging or progressing and he pretty
quickly found himself
talking with people who are scouring for
biomarkers in the urine
and realizing that there's not one magic
biomarker
but you have to do integration of
multiple biomarkers
and so we started to think about how
could i do an and operation
how could i do a higher order boolean
operation
so we took those two things together and
i'll sort of tell you the story
backwards in a way
came up with a new way of thinking about
implementing genetic logic
and it's based on a switch of the type
you can now hopefully think about
we call the switch a transcriptor
because we think it has
similarities to a three terminal
architecture used in the transistor
and it's regulating something akin to
current um but not an electrical current
a transcriptional or gene expression
current
so from these triangles you should
recognize that this is going to be
these bacteriophage integrase sites
targeting flipping
but now we're going to flip something
different we're going to flip this t
the t represents an element on dna
called a transcription terminator
okay the terminator is an element that
stops rna polymerase
once it's going along and reading out
dna it stops it says no more gene
expression pass this point
all right and these t's are a particular
type of t
they're asymmetric so what that means is
they block transcription only in one
direction on the dna
so polymerase coming from this direction
would stop polymerase coming along the
other strand would pass through
i don't know of a natural example
somebody might send it to me i'd be
really grateful for this i don't know of
any natural example of people
of of nature having evolved the flipping
of terminators
there's many natural examples of
flipping of promoters but we haven't
come across this type of architecture
in a natural system yet so the way this
works is we have this enzyme rna
polymerase
which reads out dna you think of it as a
transcriptional current
and if the terminator is in this
orientation no pass through
i have a control signal come in make an
integration flip
now because it's asymmetric terminator
in this orientation the polymerase can
go all the way through
so if my input signal is high i have a
lot of input signal i have a lot of
output signal just pure pass through the
transcriptional current
if i flip it back to its original state
it outputs low
right so the input's going to be the
transcriptable current on the left the
output's going to be the transcriptional
current on the right
and the control signal is going to be
the thing that changes the state of the
logic element right or the switch in
this case
any questions about this yes
have you observed any changes in
the overall behavior of the cell itself
from flipping its
terminators no these are exogenous
elements we're bringing in
right so so we're not uh yet using this
to rewire
the transcriptional program if you will
of a natural cell
we're thinking about that and setting
that up but right now we're just
bringing in our whole new package that's
insulated from the transcriptional
architecture of the cell to begin with
change has not happened accidentally
either
no no
other questions at this sort of basic
switch level
okay so if i have two integrases that
recognize different sites
and i connect them in series along a
piece of dna
this is going to get me an and
so in this configuration of the of the
logic elements
either the terminators would block if i
flip
via control signal one the first
terminator and i flip via control signal
to the second terminator
i get input to output pass through
if the original orientation of the
terminators is reversed
now they're allowing pass-through at the
outset
right if neither control signal shows up
i get high output
but if either or both flip then i block
this gets me a nor
so just by a simple reconfiguration of
the dna in the logic element
changing the original state of the
terminator i go from an and to a nor
here's where it gets interesting
compared to conventional electronics i
think
um so this is what an xor looks like the
output is high only if the inputs are
different
in this system in this logic element we
we've gone back to just having a single
terminator
but now we're which is flanked by
flipping sites but now that whole
package is flipped by other
flanked by additional flipping sites
right so
in this zero zero input configuration
output's low if the first control signal
is high
then the terminator's flipped and the
output's high
but if the second control signal comes
in
the whole package flips again so i'm
able to
integrate multiple control life size
control signals at a single point on my
dna wire
it'd be like having a transistor i i
don't know if can this be done or not
can i have a transistor and have it
switch the same transistor switched
by multiple signals coming into the wire
at the same point
that's one that's what i think we're
doing here and in the dna
and as a result of that architectural
feature we can implement an xor in a
single layer
right um whereas i think
in ttl or something like that if you
want to implement xor you'd have to
layer some gates
and i have to admit i'm not the
electrical engineer right so somebody
who's expert in that should be
correcting me if this is
off base but this is pretty exciting for
us and
it was in part pretty exciting because
most of the genetic engineering work
around logic gates
had been following the architectural
models established in electrical
engineering
so people had implemented xor gates but
they had done so by layering
many uh simpler gates if you will
if you want input from electrical
engineers the the transistor
analogy isn't so strong and you know you
slip into actually calling it a
transistor when you initially introduce
a transcriptor
there's gain there and it's not a binary
thing and you show
bipolar npn transistors they don't work
the way
you've described i mean there's a loose
analogy but i'm worried about people
starting to actually take it literally
yeah fair enough i think there are there
are important differences
relay logic is more like what this is
yeah
so they built transistor computers in
the 50s where you
you can latch your relay you give it a
signal and it stays in one state and
then you can unlatch it later by
putting a current the other side
transistor like you showed has a gain
where
if you use the term current rna will be
coming in one terminal or some molecule
and there'd be
proportionality of the output signal
let's get to that
i mean i i think i think you're making a
good point right the
the analogies sort of get a conversation
going they could derail a conversation
too
um i'll show you what the transfer
functions look like
yeah and let's let's keep talking
but but i i i do want to represent one
thing um
because of because we live in a world
where electronics
has dominated right or dominates a lot
of thinking
the genetic engineering community had
actually implemented the types of
architectures depicted at the bottom
which were hugely expensive to implement
in biology
um and just didn't work very well and so
it was exciting to
sort of recognize biology as its own
material right
and and come up with an architecture is
just nice
sorry oh yeah
um xnor just split the original state
i won't belabor this
these are our first generation um
logic elements they're permanent logic
elements as i'm showing you
or so they write once and they can
receive asynchronous control signals and
integrate them
um it's
we it's the it's simple to make
rewritable elements
that get pushed and then relax
spontaneously
um so we can go into that but any case
let me zoom out
so at an abstract level we've got an
input signal which is a transcription
signal coming in
we've got an output signal which is a
transcription signal going out
and we've got control signals which are
transcription signals as well
transcriptional current as well going
into the recombination controller which
means they're making integrases when
they come in
and we slot into this logic elements
types of logic elements have been
showing you are these two input logic
elements
these are right once elements
okay so we built all these
to start and we started working on this
in
june or july of last year
this is what we would predict the logic
elements
would do in terms of their output state
in response to control signal one and
control signal two
um based on models showing what the
propensity is for flipping dna at
different levels of the enzymes
and when we built these and put them
into a
population of cells and just measured
the bulk properties of the cells
this was the initial data we got back
now this is a log scale here no excuse
me it's a linear scale
and so for example you could see that
the nand gate isn't
completely symmetric right across all
the output states
it's about a twofold difference here to
here and
the or gate as well is a little bit
different
when we looked at the distributions of
single cells
and what the individual output levels as
measured indirectly by a fluorescent
protein we can't measure the
the flow of the rna polymerase this
transcriptional current if you'll permit
me that we can't measure that directly
yet
but when we look at the output
indirectly through the fluorescent
protein levels and this is now on
a log y scale from left to right
you know you can see the changes you can
see that you don't have
everything being exactly matched but
nevertheless across this whole family of
of logic elements we can create we can
identify
a threshold that can discretize the
output between
low and high and that's what that red
line represents and then score
are our false switching rates if you
will
how what type 1 and type 2 errors on the
switches
this is a detailed example of of one of
the
switching well both switching states for
the xor
what i'm showing on the y-axis is
an indirect representation of the of the
signal again it's a fluorescent protein
serving as a surrogate
for the rate of transcription the blue
contours are
the level of the control signal that's
driving the integrase
and the red contours are the
indicative of the output signal okay
and so in this case the xor gate is is
getting one of its inputs and that input
is
going up as you can see in blue and
across
this change in the input we get a
snapping up
of the output so we believe that the
gate's switching and the output goes
from low to
from from low to high the terminator has
has flipped
here's with the different control signal
the second control signal for the same
logic element
this is now driving a different
integrase with its own peculiar
biochemistry
slightly different sensitivity levels
and we get switching across this region
but with some cells not completely
switching
right and you sort of have to look
across a bigger range to see the
switching
this is pretty exciting for us because
the change in the output is bigger than
the change in the control signal
is what it looks like that you can
wiggle the control signal a little bit
and get a pretty significant change in
the output
again this is on a log y axis right so
we might be going from a arbitrary value
of 20 here
to 50 whereas the output goes from 50
to almost 3 000.
so that's a pretty big difference in
terms of the relationship between the
changing output signal and the change in
the control signal required to switch
the xor gate is our best gate right now
in terms of clean
discrete amplification or however you
want to describe it
if you look at the paper that just came
out this month last month
you can see our analysis of switching
failure rates
if you will for all the gates that we
initially developed
any questions about this or do you want
to return to
metaphor or not um
question what's what do you if you're
relating to electronics computers what
do you make your clock speed out to be
for
computation
millihertz i don't what what what's the
right
units to use for clock speed the
switching times the minimum switching
times in terms of the control pulses are
15 minutes right now
and the way i bring that back to the
biology is if you think about
bacteriophage infection
which is where we're harvesting these
parts from that decision has to be made
and implemented
on the time scale of tens of minutes so
i'd be surprised
just physically if we could drive things
much faster without
creating new selective pressures to push
the enzymes i don't know
what the limit is
we have four integrases now we could
probably barely just implement then
two two input gates that operated
independently
right or a higher order gate that
integrated signals
we come back to this if you want i
wanted to share a third result over last
year
this is work done by monica ortiz a
graduate student
in bioe here and um
she's developed this platform for cell
cell communication
that is again based on reusing
bacteriophage
and and what she basically has done is
parasitized the virus such that
the cell engineered with her system
is infected with a virus but instead of
the virus packaging up its genome
the virus will package up
any piece of dna that she targets with
her packaging signal
that chimeric virus particle or
transvestite virus particle if you will
will be secreted from the cell we're
using a bacteriophage that does not blow
up the cell
in this case the cell survives infection
and can replicate and and just continues
to broadcast these
virus particles containing monica's
messages
okay these virus particles then go out
into the environment and they infect
other cells
but they're infecting it with her
engineered messages
right the significance of this is it's
the first time
in bioengineering where the
channel for communication has been
decoupled from the message being
transmitted
previous work on engineering cell cell
communication has relied on
sending and receiving small molecule
sugars or peptides
from bacterial quorum sensing systems if
you happen to be familiar with that
and in that context the message being
transmitted is the molecule itself
right so schematically
you should recognize the top of this
lower figure
that gets implemented by having an
infected cell
which can package these arbitrary
engineered dna messages
the messaging particles get released
into the environment and they transduce
other cells you can cause the system
to in addition to transmitting the
message
also transmit infectious virus which can
turn
a population of receiver cells if you
want into rebroadcasters
okay now so you have that option
so i'll just give you a a okay let me
let me say one thing
in setting this picture up
the weakness of transmitting messages is
dna molecules as opposed to sugars or
peptides
is the dna molecules tend to be
physically larger
the virus particle in this case is a is
a interesting shape it's actually a rod
maybe 600 nanometers long and
just under 10 nanometers across right so
its spontaneous diffusion rate is quite
limited maybe
half a millimeter in 24 to 48 hours in a
jello like substrate
as opposed to these small molecule
sugars which go
two centimeters in the same period of
time just spontaneously
so one of the things monica did that was
pretty neat was to overcome the
the limited broadcasting range in these
bacteriophage messaging systems
by coupling the the packaging of the
message and the secretion of the
particle
with active cellular chemotaxis
so what's shown here is the result of
such an experiment
where she's on a 10 centimeter diameter
petri dish
plated cells that are initially red here
and initially green here and over a
period of time
it's about 24 hours they replicate but
also swim
into the fresh media such that at the
end of the
the growth experiment the green cells
have grown
from west to east and and vice versa
with the red and they meet in the middle
and they've at this point have depleted
the plate of nutrients
primarily but this is a pretty big gap
for a cell that's a micron this is a
seven centimeter gap being
you know transited in a day or so
if you look at what's happening at this
boundary um i honestly can't remember
right now if the green cells are
broadcasting or receiving or vice versa
but suffice it to say broadcasting and
receipt is happening
and some cells turn yellow okay in the
limited window of time in this
experiment where
not much can happen because as soon as
they collide they stop growing and
everything shuts down
we're seeing about um 30 of the cells
getting receipt of message okay if we do
this experiment in a in a liquid culture
where everything's mixed up
the the spontaneous receipt of message
rate meaning what i mean by spontaneous
is
you don't do a genetic selection to see
if the message got there
if you do a genetic selection say only
the cells that got the message can
survive
if i do that i'll get everything growing
that receives the message so if you want
receipt of your message make your
message essential everything else dies
in but in the absence of selection we
get about 30
transmission on the semi-solid media in
the present
in the absence of selection in liquid we
get about 93 95 percent
transmission without doing an
evolutionary
okay um so
you can communicate these logic gates
right and
um that's shown here this is an and gate
being communicated
what's neat about this is we can
communicate the because they're
permanent right once gates
we could communicate the intermediate
state of the logic element
right so we could we could have the
logic element be be transmitted
where no input signals have come in no
control signals have come in excuse me
if one or the other or both control
signals so that the messages being
broadcast
can encode the intermediate logic state
for the permanent gates at least
and that hadn't been shown before
okay so a a reprise of of
a digital data register
an introduction to amplifying logic
elements permanent elements here
i can go into details around the
rewritable and how to compose
higher order inputs 15 minute input
pulses required best case scenario
we've got four integrases right so the
scaling up
is going to be limited by harvesting of
the biochemistry
we're very optimistic about the natural
biochemistry and the diversity out there
i should mention that there's a if you
just think through this
because these enzymes are the enzymes
responsible for integration of the virus
into the host genome
they're under selection to not choose
the same dna sites to integrate into
so we expect we're going to be able to
get molecular recognition diversity in
terms of the natural integrases we won't
have to engineer
the integrases to bind different dna
although people are trying to do that
now
okay
in the context of engineering biology
this is our simplistic representation of
the core of the engineering cycle
how long does it take us to design
something how long does it take us to
build it how long does it take us to
test it
and how how many times we have to go
around this cycle to get something
working
with the data register work i started
with that took us 750 design attempts
loops around this cycle and thus three
and a half years
however coming from this course a year
ago and recognizing
what we think of of our work is now a to
d converters
we abstracted that we use them when we
implemented our logic amplifiers
every design worked the first time and
i've simply never had that experience
in engineering biology only needing to
go around this cycle once
i'm still trying to figure out i like it
but i'm still trying to figure out what
to make of it
there's background work just for context
trying to improve this cycle
and it mostly collapsed over the last
decade into three areas of fundamental
engineering work
using dna synthesis to get better at
decoupling design from fab and scaling
that up
standardizing measurement and
componentry in support of functional
composition
such that you can make reusable parts
like the a d converters
and then trying to abstract things up
from the biochemistry into a to d into
latches into switches into whoever knows
what comes next
and so i just want to i just want to
tease you with the fact that
in bioengineering one of the
fundamentally important areas of work is
this
fundamental cycle improvement work
faster more times in parallel more
smartly i don't care
but all all improvements are good and
and
what i can represent today that i
couldn't represent a year ago is after a
decade of work across many labs
we're hitting some milestones that are
pretty
interesting you know we can now do
forward compile of this is going to
sound incredibly modest but to genetic
engineering it's a big deal
we now do forward compile of of 10 gene
systems at a time
and get those genes to be expressed to
precise levels inside the cell
with very very high reliability that
outstrips our design capacity right now
very few people know how to specify the
design of a system where they tell you
up front that they care about the exact
concentrations of the proteins over time
that they want
because we just don't know enough to
design or people haven't thought through
that completely
so that's a that's an aside um but but
an important transition underway
um so happy to come back to
well let's see it's 506. so what's we go
to
5 30 or 5 15 or when do are we done
well 9 30.
5 30 right so okay so at this point
we could declare success and i'm happy
to talk about anything you wish
or i could continue to show slides and
that would probably take another
seven minutes okay
i'll tell this story backwards i went to
go visit far west fungi
which is down in monterey near monterey
in the strawberry fields
okay i'll tell you why i and how i got
there in a minute
some poor quality photographs off my
iphone
this is what it looks like there's some
sheds there's some piles of stuff
this stuff turns out to be sawdust which
is free to get
wood chips and sawdust are free to get
apparently and
they take that and they put it through
an autoclave to sterilize it in little
bags
which i'll show you in a minute they add
to it a crushed oyster shell and some
rice
husk
it comes off this assembly line those
bags are on the right they've just been
sterilized and to this they add a slurry
of a wood fungus
a solution of wood fungus to inoculate
the bag
okay they then incubate that bag for
you know a period of time maybe 72 hours
you can see the fungus
starting to grow the white material in
there
and over a 72 hour period this block of
material mostly sawdust will compile
into a physical intact block
it won't just be dust loose stuff will
be solid
you take that and rack it and what
they're doing in this
example is is cutting the plastic
wrapper
and then fruiting bodies come out which
look like this when you zoom in they
begin to look like things you would eat
um you know other types of of
cultivation
and different types of fungus growing
and so on
and it ends up in boxes like this and
goes to the supermarket
where it's really beautiful and tasty
and is organic mushroom
so this was eye-opening to me at one
level because it shows that food can
grow
from wood directly and in my world
when people talk about biofuel
manufacturing they say well we're going
to do cellulosic biofuels so we're not
competing directly with the food supply
we're not taking corn syrup into fuel
we're going right from the wood into
fuel and and this sort of brought home
that
wood is food right these things are
um half protein and half carbohydrates
in terms of if you look at the nutrient
cut
and a really impressive operation a
family operation
down there now the reason i had gone
there was this fellow named phil ross
who's an artist up in san francisco and
this is
an instance of the front page of his
website
trained in biology coming from cooking
learning sterile technique in the
kitchen
and then becoming interested in what you
can explore and make with biology
and and he's using these fungus to
grow different things not necessarily
food
his website's just his name with no
space right
you can find it pretty fast so for
example
um he took these these
bags and and made a different type of
brick out of a fungus associated with a
tea
and in a provocative museum piece
assembled these bricks into a primitive
tea house
so people could go experience a tea
house that they could drink directly
there's also growing other things um
again somewhat provocative by not being
finished in their surfaces
by growing the fungus with the 72 hour
compile time and then baking it
you get to something that's structurally
pretty impressive now there's wood
obviously but the seat and back and
sides of this chair
are from the sawdust input with the
fungus compiling it
right and then baking in and there it is
their company there's a company now
ecovediv
if i remember correctly which is growing
fungal materials for packaging
inserts and other types of of
manufacturing
this is pretty exciting for me these
these fungal growth systems
because they let me imagine being able
to compile macroscopic objects from
microscopic things
with an input that's an abundant input
now all of phil's work which is
genius in my opinion does the shaping
via extrinsic control via the mold that
shapes the dust and what the fungus
grows into
but what if we could take genetic
programs
and implement them within individual
fungal cells such that we could get to
a complementary patterning approach
which would be bottom-up program pattern
formation
this work here borrowing from
radhika nagpal and colleagues working
over a decade ago on what was then
called amorphous computing
how do you program systems to
grow into shapes right or to think about
it more abstractly
what programming language would you use
to control a pattern in four dimensions
not just a finite state machine
operating over time
but an ensemble of agents that aren't on
a grid aren't on a clock
and are using local information to make
decisions and differentiate and then
nevertheless still grow into the shape
you prescribed at the outset
so they rerun this movie from radica
it starts already a little bit into the
movie but what's happening here is a
cell at the
center of the movie is replicating uh
its descendants are transmitting
information locally
differentiating and continuing to grow
into the final pattern uh that
that you you see at the end of the movie
the color this is a simulation
this is not a physical experiment it's a
computer simulation
of an early amorphous computing program
and and the simulation stops around here
with the color representing the state
right and and that's about it now
the language that rodica and colleagues
were playing with to implement this
cross
was just a colony growth sort of
language
grow a replicate out to a particular
radius of your colony
until you hit the prescribed boundary
prescribed by the programmer
right so the programmer at the outset of
the experiment
would trace the shape they want these
cells to grow into
and then the compiler compiles down the
instructions that get placed in the
mother cell that
implements the initiates the whole
system and as those cells grow and
divide they're all running the same
program but they're differentiating
state within the programs within the
cells and so
you grow circles and keep growing
circles until you fill in
the external trace this is a pretty old
example but a simple example of how you
could think about
implementing a language for controlling
a system in three dimensions
x y and t right and you could argue it's
just two dimensions of x and y and then
it sits there
that'd be fine
so what if i start to implement oh so
i'll back up
the capacity to program and implement
this really is in part limited by
the amount of state you have that you
can control
and also by your bandwidth for
communication right
the rate at which you can get to a
pattern depends on how much messaging
you can pull off
and obviously you can imagine wanting to
integrate signals
through logic elements right so if we
can take our systems which we've
developed in bacteria and move them over
into this fungus
and scale them up a little bit we have a
chance of actually
bringing to life the the substrate to
implement program pattern formation
within the fungus in a microscopic
bottom-up way complementing what can be
shaped with the extrinsic information
and there's i mean that'd be a heroic
bit of work just to
say it for what it is and how i'm
relating it might not be perfectly right
but that's how i'm thinking about it um
part of the reason i'm thinking about
this is because throughout biology we
see a lot of different
types of programmed pattern formation
which is an understatement we're all
familiar with this i'll just give you a
weird example coming from the world of
sponges
where in the ocean you see sponge
pulling together silica and making
pretty impressive stuff
which includes structural members fiber
optic cables
and and so on this is the basket sponge
from the pacific ocean
and it's it's skeleton shown here work
done very nicely by joanna eisenberg
then at bell labs but but now at harvard
um
so so what if i could implement program
pattern formation in in wood fungus what
if i could power them with sawdust and
what if i could begin to bring into that
platform for replication and pattern
formation
biocatalysis of materials and deposition
of materials
so that's that's what i'm thinking about
sort of moving towards on a next decade
time scale
as a as a growth market if you will
for logic memory communication
here's another example program pattern
formation which is which i just have
found impossible
to ignore now being out here for a
couple years
i have a pine tree like this in my front
yard in menlo park and
right this time of year it starts doing
this starts making pine cones
the pine cones are enormous and they
fall off
in a month or so and and they get taken
away and we do nothing with them
um so i'm very curious about this sort
of surplus manufacturing capacity we
have around here
in menlo park if you look at the
composting rates in menlo park it's
so far as i can tell about 16 million
pounds of garden clippings a year
which is 500 pounds per person per year
that's a lot of matter being compiled
annually and not being used for
manufacturing
so so it's it's a big picture dream but
i'm
keen to take ownership in a limited
sense of program pattern formation
couple that to
inorganics and deposition of inorganics
and change how we begin to manufacture
stuff
so that's the fungus story for anybody
who wanted to know what that was
and this might be my last slide
i mean truly people have been talking
about circuits and genes for a while
this is really
coming close to real logic it's a it's
very impressive
the but coming from the engineering
profession
a lot of people who view this
see people calling it engineering
biology who aren't engineers
the engineers themselves go well this is
basic science akin to when the nobel
prize was awarded for developing a
transistor
they got it for physics and so the
engineers
tend to think we take pride in building
things to solve a problem or serve a
purpose and
i don't think it's there yet so it seems
a bit of a misnomer to call it
engineering versus
modification or something maybe less
less grand
i i don't mean to be argumentative i'm
just
it's a philosophical point that
engineers do bring up a lot in their
hallway conversations that is this
really bioengineering or engineered
biology
isn't it really exploration in the sense
of physics
be getting the transistor then the
circuits follow um
it's a good it's a good comment and
questions
along with it um
and i'll have to think about it honestly
what i experience
is bioengineering whatever it is today
exists in the context of everything
that's come before
and so we are burdened with
and inspired by simultaneously
the work to develop the hunks of metal
that were reference objects for
measuring current in wires and improving
manufacturing and telegraph engineering
the 1800s in britain
the basic science leading to the or
applied science leading to the
transistor or whatever it was
mead conway vlsi decoupling design and
fab uh
william sellers and standardization of
screwed threads in 1864 in philadelphia
the work in segovia spain 2 thousand
years ago to standardize rock
the work in stanford over 100 years ago
to grind up artificial stone and make
that fancy tiled diamond pattern around
the original quad
all of this hits us simultaneously
and and so it's an
overload to experience it as somebody
working and trying to figure out where
is my valid home
i'll simply represent that we're doing
the things we're doing
i feel that i'm an engineer i'm trained
as a
civil engineer i worked for amtrak one
summer
on construction management projects and
i'm shocked come into the world of
biology and not
see the engineering infrastructure well
developed
whether that's because the science isn't
there or the infrastructure is there or
both
i don't know stanford having helped
invent genetic engineering
a human generation ago never started a
department of genetic engineering
here we are
other things i could represent over over
the last year
would for example highlight papers where
if you take the idea of a standard
biological part
we've we've now moved that area of work
forward such that
people should ask don't just tell me
what the part does but tell
me how likely the part is to do that
function
as it's reused with other parts as the
environment in which it operates changes
in other words
a quality score a second order statistic
and we proposed doing that work
in 1999 it took us 10 years to get the
funding to do that work
because all the funders just wanted us
to cure disease
they didn't want us to make all
combinations of parts and see what
happens and then
develop a mathematical model to
interpret variation across changes in
context
but having done that work and scoring
various types of junctions among parts
that were really poorly behaved meaning
high variation
we could then prioritize a next round of
work to see if we could push that
variation down and we did
and nobody had done that before and
you know the answers oftentimes are in
the natural genetic architectures that
we don't know how to appreciate
but when we bring first order
engineering goals
to the biological substrate sometimes we
see the biology in a new light and get
the functional compositional solutions
we want
and then sometimes in the example i
showed here we come up with new
architectures
that we don't see in the natural
examples so
so i don't honestly know how to directly
respond to your question
and i'll just simply relate we're at an
interesting time where every past
experience is sort of converging
on biology as a substrate as a type of
material
and so what do you make of that
if i were to pause zoom out and come
back into the question
and mount an argument in favor of
bioengineering as an engineering
discipline
i would immediately represent that we
don't have the discipline right now
but i would also argue that we could
expect the discipline to develop
in a way that's likely to be
sufficiently
unique and independent of other modes of
engineering and mostly this comes to the
physics of the substrate
biological material is a different type
of material we've got self-mixing
systems
due to the thermal noise we have very
high heterogeneity within the systems
it's not like just repeating the same
thing over and over again
so it really pushes beyond any existing
tool for complexity management i've seen
we've got reproducing systems so how do
i design a system that exists not just
on the time scale performance and
learning via memory
state change but but it exists on this
third time scale
of reproduction
and then it also has this um it was a
comment
as somebody walked in looking at the
title side i think
said that looks dangerous if we actually
make any progress on getting better at
engineering biology everybody freaks out
the ramifications on this area of work
are just
impressive um so
and there's one more reason it doesn't
come to me right now but but i would
argue that
it's already apparent that the
living matter is just a different type
of stuff and the track record over the
last decade is
we're actually getting systematically
better going around the design build
test loop
and if we keep pushing on that for a
long while
i think you get to a new engineering
discipline that's not just on a
powerpoint slide but actually is
substrate distinct it's distinctive and
that thus engineering solution
distinctive or engineering approach
distinctive
so i'd value talking about it more right
it was just those sort of two things
would be the major modes of
what i'm reflecting on engineers
it's physics till you ship a product
that's the mantra
yeah so so genetic engineering how much
how much money did electrical engineers
ship
in terms of product what's the market
value of electrical engineers
products in the u.s last year uh
globally it's about 300 billion
electronics industry so in the united
states genetic engineering products were
300 billion last year
well i've heard rob carlson's talks too
i mean this is
no but i mean i think i think there's
that element too which is
these tools are being used to ship
product
right the market for genetically encoded
data storage that operates in light in
live cells today is approximately zero
dollars a year
and and uh the product we're shipping
you know our logic gates are being
immediately reused by people
in the medical school who are studying
how bacteria colonize the gut
and they want to know what the signals
are at different
crypts in your gut right so they're
research tools i would say
you know but there's gen encore with
1980s engineered subtle license for
better soap
right and uh that has a market impact
and it also has a
impact in reducing our domestic hot
water energy requirements so you don't
have to heat up your wash temperature
wash water temperature i'm sorry
yeah yeah so i i would take issue with
the with we're not shipping product
that's wrong this stuff
ship product from what you're talking
about here that's what i mean
sure people are doing genetic
engineering and shipping slightly
modified subtilizen
by the kiloton there's no doubt yeah but
no one shipping bacterial logic
i would agree i would agree
i agree and we didn't have it until this
month
yeah and and but yeah i would agree i
would agree that's a good point
that's a good point and we certainly
have to do that right i mean if we don't
develop
markets and products around this it
doesn't go
period i don't see how it goes yeah
in the test experiments it's an
exogenous factor
in the applications like what i just
mentioned where people are using it to
assay and record state within a mouse
gut
it's endogenous transcription factors so
you could imagine
a natural micro but sort of goes back to
the gentleman's question earlier
you can integrate the neat thing about
these logic elements is they take a
transcription current in they take a
transcription current out they're pretty
compact package
so you can insert them anywhere in a
natural chromosome where there's a
transcriptional current
right and so
in the application sector and when you
get to applications you're driving
you're driving input output and control
signals with the native signals you're
basically
patching in to the native transcription
signals does that make sense
well changing state yes you just
you just added i mean you had an
environment you just you got it so
so we're doing switching here we have
cells they have the switch running
writing a sugar or a circuit of a sugar
and the cells respond to that they
initiate a transcription signal
that makes the enzyme that causes the
thing to switch
so we have to add a molecule to the
culture bacteria that then gets
transduced into the cell to create a
transcription signal
that triggers switching
um i have a pot of bacteria i add a
sugar to it
the gates switch yeah
if i wanted to apply them that so that's
just for developing and testing them
so we can control the adding of the
sugar when you go to apply them
you want to connect into the natural
signals within the cell
or whatever it is you're trying to react
to so you integrate the gates into that
context
in these experiments certainly right
these are the best studied
switching sugars around in biology
arabinose right yeah
anyway yes but they're just they're just
the experimental tools right it'd be
like asking is that a
is that a is that a is that a special
switch
right from texas instruments yeah it's
special right but it's the one that
works
yeah yeah try
after switch if you want it to switch
back down
what should we do okay for the
architectures i'm showing here
these are permanent gates they're right
once gates
so they're only switching and they're
not going back okay
if you want to see
if you pull the paper that's referenced
in the talk
and you go into the supplement
figure s2 supplementary figure 2 here's
the architecture for the
rewritable gates okay and
you just basically have to reverse a lot
of the the architecture of the switches
so instead of pulsing the integrase
we're going to
pulse the the directionality factor so
you just you just reverse things up a
little bit
and this will push and then revert back
spontaneously
right so just just check out
supplementary figure two see if you can
make sense of it but
but pretty simple changes get you
rewritable
and this is what the gates look like for
yeah excuse me you could make rewritable
gates
that have internal state or memory
right like with the data register but
that would be more complicated
right so what i'm showing you here is
sort of a push and relax push and relax
architecture so you might just have to
play around with with what these symbols
mean and check it out or talk with me
later yeah the applications that you
mentioned towards the beginning of the
talk had to do with something like say
a counter for biological events yeah now
before such a counter becomes practical
how much of a speed up do you think we
would need
in the switching speed of these
biological circuits before we could do
something i think we got to get to
15 minutes right so i think we're going
to be at the performance limits of the
enzymes
right so that would be eight-fold
improvement
over what we shipped in may of 2012.
what's your doubling rate yeah but so so
so the fastest doubling rate you're
going to get for e-cola
the last time you measured before that
you said you were eight minutes oh
well we went from we went from what did
i say 10 hours 12 hours to two and a
half hours
so it's right but but yeah
let's let's not go there because i don't
have decades
of data to show that trend right
yeah it would take or do you think it's
it's feasible to do that get it down to
15 minutes
i certainly think it's feasible um
a couple months that's what your project
focus was
i mean our focus is on exploring
different logic element architectures
um jerome's super excited to ship a
product
right he's going into medical
diagnostics you know he's got these
gates
being driven off of urine samples right
so so you know this is um
not a not a populated space there aren't
a lot of people working on this
right tim lew's group at mit has done
some nice work
in this space and
i think so i mean people are starting to
use these pretty fast
but very few people are working on this
the the number of biologists working on
serine recombinases of the type we like
most of all
are two graham hatful in pittsburgh are
you working on them no no no and maggie
smith in england
right so this is not a um a
hyper-populated space
yeah what is the situation in this space
um we pushed our logic element
architectures in the public domain kara
stanford paragraph three
patent policy um
we filed on the data register
because others had filed out of bu
and mit and those filings looked
well i won't say more
but we think we're far enough ahead and
have priority around the logic elements
that we
we just pushed it public domain first to
invent its first to file
yeah but we did this last year
and have and have and have our and have
a lot of things documented
through doi and d space and stuff like
that um so i like our chances
on the logic stuff
um there's a lot of typically this space
defaults to patents
and um uses of genetic functions right
so the the supreme court decisions
that are in the u.s playing out right
now
the the bowman versus monsanto case
having to do with whether or not
patent exhaustion applies as product
replicates itself
that would have some impact on this
space the myriad
genetics case around the breast cancer
diagnostics which is probably
thought of as a more important decision
has more to do with composition of
matter not uses of function
so that actually won't impact the type
of work i do
um so i would say the default path is
is a lot of patenting and and messy
patenting and
more patenting than commercialization if
you will
so i don't think that's a good balance
and puts a lot of things at risk in
terms of integration especially as
especially as the design build test
cycle changes
you know we're actually reusing parts
now we're actually abstracting things
we're actually outsourcing compile
and and separating design and fab and
and you know
we gotta we got to make some
architectural improvements around
property rights
for example i don't know if anybody here
would
would get up and cheer for the dmca but
one of the nice things about that act
was the
is the carrier exemption uh such that if
you're
uh intermediary redistributing
copyrightable works
you're you're not accruing liability
associated with that so long as you take
to first approximation as i understand
it but in the world of technology where
patents are used you don't have the
equivalent of a of the carrier exemption
right so if i'm a dna synthesis company
if i'm a gene synthesis company if i'm a
if i'm a plasmid redistribution house
shipping
around dna molecules i'm actually
accruing liability by enabling people to
infringe potentially on third-party
patents and i have
no way to clear that right i've no i
have no immunity from it and
an exemption from it and no way to clear
fto
and that that problem is for example um
disallowing people in companies who
build automated strain engineering new
fabs basically that are better than
anything else that exists
it's it's not allowing them to open up
to outside users
we can't implement moses in partnership
with academia and industry
in genetic engineering right now because
of the property rights puzzles around
liability associated with intermediaries
handling patented materials
so from the microscopic um
there's filings around this type of
stuff and and then at the macroscopic
the architecture
isn't working very well another way to
think about it is um
biotechnology is going to struggle to
figure out is it going to reorient
itself from sort of deep verticals
focused on specific applications
to many many more sort of layers of
platform tech
and and if it does that reorientation
the property right is going gonna have a
lot to say about it
looked at or tried using the biochemical
changes that happen in the cell
during division or just like right up
into a division that's the input for
flipping
yeah that's the thought i mean to be
quite honest we're we're
close to having a push-on push-off
toggle right
and that's been most of the most of the
focus on on that over the year
we have shipped a bunch of uh
theoretical designs and analysis of how
to scale up counters
to eight bit combinatorial asynchronous
counters and other types of
architectures
those are all theoretical and we're
limited with four integrations right now
so so practically we haven't pushed too
hard on integration into the application
we know that there are cell division
cycle dependent signals
it'd be interesting to know whether or
not to lot of work to do right so it'd
be interesting though should you should
you plug into a transcriptional
activation signal
or should you plug into a proteolysis
signal there'd be different types of
signals
um but it is it's a little bit too early
for us we don't have a systematic
program
pushing towards that right now another
way to say it just
just to give you a little bit of context
what i'm showing here represents
sort of the end of a 10-year 11-year
research cycle
right everybody associated with these
projects is graduating
with degrees or postdocs and getting
other positions
and so we're really in this period of
renewal and
you know it's why you hear me explore
something seemingly wacky like wood
fungus and what can we do with that
well maybe that's what we're going to do
or maybe we return and say actually
we're going to get an epic counter that
works in
stem cells human stem cells let's go do
that
so so and there's no chance that we're
at risk of saturating the space
either from research or application
so we we know of those things they're
peripheral in the adjacent and we'll see
what we or other people do
i'm sort of hopeful perhaps not
completely naively that
because we've taken such care to
implement our systems with uh
in ways that are agnostic to the inputs
and the outputs
that it'll be easier for other people to
reuse them and we're starting to see
that
not with the data storage so much as the
um with the logic elements
there seems to be a lot of demand in the
research community to use those
i don't know if that counts as shipping
a product it doesn't sound like soul of
a new machine
quite yet but we'll see
nsf um darpa has
a living foundries program
which is working on tool layer stuff
the biggest public fundings overseas
right now china and the uk
have the most focused programs to do
work like this minister willets in
united kingdom
is a significant champion of getting
better at engineering biology
so but in the us i would say nsf and
arpa
are the folks who are investing in the
get better at engineering part
and nothing else is
super well organized i would i would
acknowledge that a significant
development has been missed
out of the department of commerce in the
u.s so national institutes of standards
and tech
is um is making synthetic biology
priority area
for for investment and they're shipping
people to stanford who just started this
week they're shipping a group of people
to stanford to work on
biological measurements led by mark
salad
so he just sold his house in maryland
and bought a house out here and he's
coming out here
to lead a group to work on stuff
and and metrology work is going to be a
big deal we have no reference objects
that work inside living cells to first
approximation
and as we've explored that just a little
bit they work really well
to remove types of variation and make
measurements
reusable across locations and over time
so it's kind of shocking that basic work
hasn't been done in support of
engineering
so let me acknowledge nsf and arpa and
nist newly to the game
doe is obviously spending a lot of money
but they're spending that money on
on sort of targeted projects making bulk
commodity project
products like biofuels um and
less on infrastructure although to be
fair they're
spending a lot on scientific
infrastructure like the genome center in
walnut creek that sequences microbes and
plants
i want to give them credit but you know
the obama white house released the
bioeconomy blueprint in may about a year
ago
and it hasn't been really popular to
talk about it
politically there is not a plan for
advancing biotechnology there are not
things that lead to structured
public-private partnerships there are
not industry consortia
you know that say wow this is
strategically important for us to get a
lot better
at building silicon or whatever building
dna right just
none of that maturity is in the space
so i shouldn't represent that we have a
plan um we neither have a plan with
respect to tech development
we also don't have a plan with respect
to policy
so and and people are really struggling
to understand
at a policy level what is the
significance of of decoupling design and
fab what is the significance of having
standards that enable coordination of
labor and reuse of parts
all of our all of our frameworks for
example for biosafety
are coupled to a strong institutional
oversight model
or stanford's in charge of biosafety at
stanford and so
the institution will take care of it the
people at stanford be responsible the
institution was responsible to
government
but you know if if
you know the the recent example on
kickstarter of
of a group raising so far maybe a
quarter million dollars to make a
glowing plant
right um outside of a strong
institutional oversight framework who's
in charge of that who's responsible for
that
well right now that's defaulting to the
civil society organizations that are
against promulgation of genetically
engineered organisms
so they're trying to run a kickstopper
campaign to counter the kickstarter
campaign
so that's that's the state of play right
just just sort of expanding from your
innocent question who's paying for all
this
yeah it's not it's not very many people
and it's not well organized
which creates a neat opportunity because
it's not that expensive either
you know the team i i work with here is
five people
right yeah what are the issues here
short term and long term the the meta
safety issue is
we're doing okay with biosafety it's not
perfect
um you know we had a 25 year old
researcher die in san francisco last
year from the va
he was working with a natural microbe
associated with meningitis if i remember
correctly
he infected himself on a friday and and
was dead saturday in his
treasure island apartment so laboratory
by safety is a
real issue um that issue predates
genetic engineering
paul berg and others led the
conversation around how to wrap genetic
engineering into the biosafety framework
and that's worked pretty well it's not
perfect but it's worked pretty well you
could almost say it's worked too well
because we spend too much energy on it
we don't take enough risks so
there's another type of death which is
associated with lack of progress
but but the meta issue with respect to
biosafety is um
generational renewal right so my
students weren't alive when genetic
engineering was invented
and and so they'll grow up in a few
years and be the leaders with respect to
biosafety not just the practitioners
and so we sort of have to pass the baton
of critical thinking and community
leadership and responsibility to a
next generation of people and and that's
possible to do security is a is a
different
topic so so how do you deal with
intentional misapplication of
biotechnology
nobody has a plan for that
there's a very nice course being offered
at stanford right now
called surgery 222 offered by an er
doctor
and the topic is biosecurity and she's
done a brilliant job
of bringing people together to talk
about it and the students in that course
are amazing
but i i would be fair to say nobody has
a strategy for securing an open
distributed network
that's based on the living world as
people can increasingly
inject intention to that i don't
consider that to be an immediate
short-term risk although bad things
could happen right away
i think it's a longer-term strategic
puzzle that's
probably uh one of the bigger ones
around
yeah artificially intelligent
growing crud that takes over everything
right that's the beauty of this right
biology's already taken over the planet
yes that's right right
so as george whitesides you know
observed green you don't
you don't have to worry about grey goo
it's green goo it's already won
and and what's that like a beautiful
green
it's running this time yeah you need to
be careful right because because if
they're 10 to the 31 fade you can infer
that there's several order of magnitude
more bases of dna
right so like 10 to the 35th 10 to the
36 bases of dna
on the on the planet now we've sequenced
as a as a civilization 10 to the 15th
today
if i believe juan ming yang's numbers
from the beijing genomics institute
so we've got 10 to the 20-fold to go
just in terms of sequencing if we could
somehow magically sequence every base of
dna on the planet
including many redundant bases our
synthesis capacities aren't anywhere
near that
they lag sequencing so so yeah you could
release things today to amplify and take
off but
in a way that be a successive evolution
not engineering i would agree with that
scientific versus engineering frame and
i don't think we're going to be able to
do that
to be honest anytime
soon i think i think the you know i
think the
the limited environments that we
impact directly or indirectly which are
big environments is where
things will play out and and just to
put a number to that right we do
impact something like 75 of the land
arable land on the planet
so that we're impacting a lot already so
i don't want to say it's not going to be
a lot but
but in terms of nature natural
biodiversity i don't think we're going
to have a big impact
except the impact associated with what's
going on anyway which is horrible
loss of diversity through ecological
change and destruction